How is the operating system
able to meet the requirements
that we have identified for it?
And one of them is this requirement
that the trusted part be isolated and
not be tampered with by the untrusted
application or the user code.
For us to be able to do that,
we're going to see that we going to
need help from the hardware.
Okay so,
remember operating system layered on top
of the hardware that we have.
But, the hardware has to implement
certain functionality and that
has to do with protecting memory where
the trusted system is going to reside.
And so
the hardware is going to help us protect
the trusted part of the system
from untrusted applications.
And that is actually going to be
the reason we're going to able to
isolate it or make it time for proof.
When you talk about isolating then,
we also ever talk about, well something
has to be different when you're
executing user or application code.
Worse is when you actually go into the
operating system or when your executing
their trusted software that
makes up the operating system.
Well the hardware actually's going to
do something else for us that
processor that is executing actually
is going to execute in different modes.
Execution modes say either
I am executing user code
that is in our trusted, or
I am executing system code.
So the processor is actually aware of
what kind of code it is executing.
So one obvious thing we can do
when it's executing user code for
example the process I'm in user mode.
I shouldn't be touching anything that
belongs to the operating system or
the trusted base that we have.
The trusted computing base that we have.
When I'm executing in the system mode.
Then I'm allowed to access the code and
the data that makes up
the trusted system.
So the hardware is sort of aware of
what is going on at a given time.
In particular what execution
mode is it running in.
The execution mode for
this goes by a different name it
is also called execution rings.
So ring is sort of think about
a privilege level in some sense.
When you are in the system mode,
you have the highest privileges and
there could be many of these in fact
several processor architectures support
more than two.
And I'm just talking with user and
system.
But, the innermost ring, where
the trusted computing base resides,
the most privileged.
As you move out of that, you, for
example, could move into the user ring.
And then your privileges are reduced,
because you can't access what
can be accessed by being in
the trusted computing base.
So this execution mode that we're
talking about, whether you're in system
mode or user mode, you can also
say you are in the ring that
you reside in when you are in system
mode versus the user ring, or mode.
So it goes by different names,
either execution modes,
system, supervisor,
a variety of these names.
But the idea here is
that the processor for
the hardware knows that it's,
you know, execution state is such
the state indicates the mode
that we're talking about.
So it's either running with higher level
of privileges, it can do certain things
that it's only allowed to do when
it's running the trusted code, or
it's executing the non-trusted or
untrusted code when it's in user mode.
So again, memory protection but
then this processor being aware of
what its execution mode is, that's
something else that we're going to need
to meet the trusted computing base
that we had identified for ourselves.
So, if you are in different modes,
we said you should be able to do more
things when you are in the system or
more privileged mode, compared to when
you are in user or less privileged mode.
Well, certain hardware instructions,
they're called privileged instructions.
They can only be executed when the
processor is in the inner most ring or
the most privileged ring or
is in the system mode.
Or ring zero it's called.
Zero is the most privileged and
you go out, zero, one, two, three and
become less privileged.
So privileged instructions
are special instructions
that you cannot execute when
you are in the user mode.
Okay lot of times these
instructions sort of
help you figure out what parts of
memory you access for example.
Or these are hardware devices
that we have need to control.
These kinds of instructions
direct access to the hardware
we said is not available to user code.
Similarly what parts of memory you
can access can not be manipulated
at user level.
If it could be then you can go
access somebody else's memory.
So those kind of actions require
user instructions that can only
be executed in the system mode.
And these instructions are called
privileged instructions or instructions
that can be executed in high privileged
level, a ring or more that you're in.
So one of the ways in which
we're going to be able to meet
the requirements that we identified for
a trusted computing base is by
making use of a number of different
things the hardware does for us.
It has memory protection,
it gives us these execution
modes we're talking about.
It also has special instructions
that cannot be executed
when we are not in the right mode.
So, with this support from the hardware,
we will see we will be able to do
isolation or the tamper resistance
that is one of the requirements for
a trusted computing base.